and I won't be doing any more interviews
with your little Top-Up bearded balls
[Music]
welcome back to the true Jordan YouTube
channel ladies guest is the heavyweight
champion of the world Tyson Fury so
Tyson how are you today are you all
right good yeah I've uh I've been
thinking about this influencer boxing I
wondered if you'd seen uh ksi's last
fight by any chance just before we start
I've got 40 minutes yeah
yeah
right gone continue all right uh ksi's
last fight did you uh did you see it
I didn't I'm not gonna lie I um I didn't
see him when did he fight uh it was like
a month ago he was interested in
fighting Tommy I think obviously him and
Jake Paul have got this thing Tommy's
involved I wondered what you thought
training camp for a real fight
um sorry I don't watch all that uh
YouTube stuff all right not I've got
anything against it I think it's great
for the sport and great for the people
who do it great for everybody but it's
not my cup of tea if I want to see a
real fight I go down to a more composer
on a Friday night and I watch a fight
we uh we have Deontay Wilder uh your
former uh for um obviously fighting
recently and he uh he went by knockout
uh had a bit of a cry afterwards seemed
a bit of a different block what did you
make of that very different to where he
was with you after after the fight
um maybe I knocked a better sense into
him and maybe he's been humble from the
three beatons that I gave the soccer
he's a former knockout victim of the
Gypsy King uh-huh do you think that
softened him up a little bit and made
him realize that maybe so yeah yeah I
think so you never know though you know
mum's gotta do what mum's got to do and
if that's what he needs to do then
that's what he needs to do it's
interesting because he showed you no
respect after the fight and yet then
there he is crying uh it was bizarre for
me to watch to be honest yeah to be
honest with you it's none of my business
what they do to be fair Connor Ben
that's the big news of the day I wanted
to get a little bit of your uh
impression of this uh he tested positive
for a female fertility drug
and obviously we were hearing uh from
Eddie Hearn that when everything comes
out uh we all realize that Connor was
probably innocent today it's come out
that two tests from two separate
occasions uh from a month apart or at
least a month apart were uh both
positive and the only thing that they're
saying is contamination is what was
their excuse for it what do you make of
it again it's not on my business so
don't get involved and again like you're
speaking to Tyson Fury the Gypsy King I
Am My Own man I'm not sheep I don't
follow the the cliche of oh let's talk
about someone because it's in fashion I
don't give a toss what they do none of
my business I keep their snows in what
concerns me
and I don't get involved in other
people's business
period right okay fair play none of my
concern what kind of has does it's about
Ken Stone he's not in my Division I
don't I don't focus on what they do in
their lives
um I have no interest what fertility
drug they take I don't care maybe he's
trying for Twins then he's um taken IVF
I don't know and I don't really care I
guess the part of the reason I was
interested is because Eddie Hearn was
one of the biggest uh speakers on behalf
of Conor Ben and um you've had your back
and forth with Eddie and in regards to
the Anthony Joshua fight collapse which
is your business he tried to point the
finger at you blaming you for your
deadlines saying it was your fault and
not his fault looking back at that whole
situation it did become a bit of a mess
how do you feel about that now
you know I'm over at Ian and Joshua so
if they want to blame me play me I'll
tend to blame no problem it was all Me
I'm Scared muscles them weights he left
and all that how much of a badass is and
those three losses in his last five
fights he absolutely terrified me so
yeah blame me I'm the man take I'll be
the four guy don't care I'm just over
him don't want to mention I'm not
interested in them at all there will be
no more contact or no more mention of
those soccer back of the queue out of
the line and in the cold with Wolves
nowhere to go
um yeah
they blamed on the on these deadlines
you said and I guess they're confusion
yeah I don't blame them for blaming on
the deadlines probably good good blaming
deadlines you know if he if if there's a
deadline set you know you know what
deadline means don't we
do we all know what a deadline means
I hear you yeah I mean if you don't do
something in a certain time when someone
took a new a bone or giving you a job
then you lose opportunity
and that opportunity is now flown so you
know it's uh no no interest what they do
in their lives or their careers
um
the confusion comes from um from the
outside looking in anyway and this is
something that a lot of your fans have
commented on is chisora has the same
promoter same management team and yet he
he didn't get a deadline is there a
reason for that she's already didn't get
that line because I just agreed or
publicly there was no deadline into our
knowledge because obviously you made it
very public about the AJ deadline
whereas chisora seemed to get extra time
and that seemed to be a much smoother
process why why was that different
shazara's got balls there's nothing
there's no um p's and q's about it just
always got balls stepped up to the
player great to Define greater
everything that it was on the table
that's a fun point of view obviously I
make videos but ultimately I'm a fan I'm
a fan of you you're one of my favorite
Fighters and the the things that made me
uh connect with you and many others is
like you always seem to to take on
challenges that other people wouldn't do
from Klitschko going into his backyard
or or taking the Wilder fight after
you'd been through you know the hell and
back and the way you took on your mental
health uh difficulties in public I
always felt like there's a man who takes
on a challenge and that's why this this
chizora fight I think is rubbing people
up the wrong way is because it it
doesn't feel like you're doing your
usual thing that we love you for which
is it's not a challenge for you
what is a challenge though getting an
opponent's a challenge yeah that's the
challenge first of all when I made you a
mirror turn and come back fine I I
offered it to Alexander ruseck he said
he wanted um the WBC crown and it was
held by gypsies I think we all seen that
video I said it is held by gypsies held
by the Gypsy King yeah
you want it come and get it so he was
offered um a very lot of money which I'm
not a liberty to say on camera to fight
on December 3rd but he said he needed a
six months training camp or some
stupidness like that I don't know I
don't get involved in an Integrity
um so he declined it so then I went to
the why not take the six months old why
not wait for a use
Aura because I um it's my career why
would I wait for somebody else some
little Ukrainian foreign
boxing I don't dance to somebody else's
tune
their times will come whether they step
up to the plate they step up to the
plate but you know it uh when you get
offered a fight by somebody and you're
in a position to take it you know what
you gotta take it because if you don't
that bird will fly away and you're going
to lose the opportunity that's all very
logical and uh definitely no arguments
with what you've said there it's it's
just that
um it feels like there could have been
other fighters who you haven't fought in
the top 50 and who would have also taken
the opportunity you know who would have
offered a lot more Intrigue to your fans
than chisora when you've obviously
easily before
effect beat um Joshua didn't he quite
easily yeah
called away
um 50 55 so if chizora is no good then
never zusek
potentially I mean you know that's a
fair argument but also it's more just
the Intrigue for funds we want
interesting matchups and I mean you beat
chisora with one arm behind your back
basically and to a point where it was
getting booed last time a long time ago
but I also beat Deontay Wilder twice and
then did a rematch with him and I can
guarantee it it won't be one person in
the world who would not want to see a
four fight between me and why about I've
already beat him three times so even if
you want to go out Liberty two times in
a draw
but people will see that again right I
think people would want to see it
because Deonte has that X Factor in his
hand and he can change a fight at any
moment whereas chisora he's lost 50 of
his last 50 in fights and even the last
fight he won was a raise a thin decision
and the other three uh it was last four
were losses so very close losses to high
level opponents oh
oh they are high level there's no doubt
yeah yeah he started
good victories along the way as well I
just think that we've seen so much of
you in chisora enough to know has the
old dog learn new tricks I mean it
doesn't it doesn't look like he's
getting better with Parker battering him
the way he did and it just looks like
it's an easy money fight for you I don't
think that that's what you've put
yourself across as you're about which is
why there's some confusion there for
your fans you're like well it's also
it's also history making
why is the history Megan
I'm going to Enlighten you okay I'll be
the first heavyweight champion in
history to complete two trilogies so and
now you know why it makes more sense to
fight him than some foreign person and
nobody knows so also you take the top
15. there is a few foreigners in there
who nobody knows about yeah one defeated
records but when I fight them foreigners
people don't I'm not interested anyway
you're better off with somebody you know
who's a household name who people can
relate to and support and sing Oh Derek
chazora then somebody you can't even say
the guy's name who would never heard of
it could be [__] he could be good so you
pick somebody out the top 15. pick one
anybody you want
wouldn't be ready for the third okay
don't forget we've been through all of
these things from my point of view I
hear you compared a lot to the grits and
for me you're right up there you know
but the difference is is I think with
Muhammad Ali with Lennox Lewis you look
back at their career and and you can say
these guys fought everyone in their era
and right now that seems to be a real
struggle for you I'm not saying it's
your fault there's only there's only
Joshua left of my error
I'll say and you couldn't make invite me
if he's going to give it I think Joyce
all all pose interesting questions
they come from a different era they were
still changing nappies when I was a
champion I was World Heavyweight
Champion though while they were boxing
for a plastic cup so I mean either way I
think it adds to your legacy and when
you talk about Legacy one thing that you
underestimate
um my friend is I don't give one damn
about Legacy I'm not with a fair bit
though right you talk about the greatest
ever a lot I don't talk about that at
all because when I'm finished from
boxing do you know what I don't care
about what people think about me or how
many belts I want more what fights
didn't happen it's no interest you go
back to all the press conferences and
see no interest in Legacy no interest in
being remembered no interest in belts
check it out after your last okay I I
have heard you say this before but I've
also heard you say I'm the greatest of
all time many many times and to me if
that's not of interest of you why see it
because I am I beat any man born from
his mother but you have proven that is
my point you can't prove it because you
can't go back in time and fight all the
great you can only beat whoever's
informed yeah I'm not saying okay well I
think what is it that you're getting out
here anyway
I think the chisora fight is a is a is
for you're charging the Great British
public hard-earned money to watch this
on pay-per-view and when you've already
beaten them twice and he's shown that
yeah
and people still paid for it I think
Johnny Wilder is of a much more
dangerous fight as hence why he put you
down multiple times whereas chisora he
ain't gonna put you down if he's in
there with a hammer with you you know we
can't put anybody down yeah
how do you know that I don't believe so
because he struggled so much with the
last time that the crowd were burned
towards the end of the fight because it
was so hard has done what he's got to do
and no matter what you say or what you
people like you want to say about Derek
chisora he's achieved more than in
boxing and in fighting than 10 men like
you could ever achieve I agree I'm not
just when I let you sit here and fight
somebody who's fought the best fighters
of this house
to be in there with you anymore
in your heart
and he's done a lot he's still a lot in
the sport and he deserves his payday and
I'm willing to give him and that's
that's about the is this about the Pia
day for chisora for you a little bit is
this you sorting out an old mate a
little bit
and that's it look forward to it and if
you don't want to watch it then please
don't and if you do tune in and if you
don't want to buy a ticket don't buy a
ticket and if you do we'll let the rest
of the 50 on 60 on Thousand that's
already bought tickets so all right one
last question about you sir I beg to
differ with you because it's already
been over 60 000 tickets sold so
somebody's obviously interested in the
fight well I think people are interested
in you because you you are great and I
don't dispute that for one second Tyson
but what people really want you to see
where I'm coming from I can't let you
probably never in a fight in your life
brunch with aura down he's fought
everybody I'm not doing that happen I'm
just saying the facts always lost 50 of
his last 50 in fights and isn't it
World level and he thought he thought
that well what is now the unified
heavyweight champion the world and he's
like punched him all the way so somebody
who can't fight doesn't do that I never
said he can't fight though what I'm
saying is with his record right now I
don't think he should be getting a world
title fight and I think there's a
potential in boxing for people to get
badly hurt when they're mismatched and I
think that this is a mismatch I don't I
think the heavyweight fights and
anything can happen
because you're only one punch away from
Victory if jazara does it I think the
world would be happy for him even you
you'd be the one on the receiving end of
it big thanks for taking the uh the
interview Tyson I understand where
you're coming from appreciate you and
Derek are legends of British boxing all
respect in that sense and I wish you the
best of luck mate
have you worked out to close this phone
are you all right
at the bottom
well that went well you ever been cussed
out by the heavyweight champion of the
world probably not very glad I did this
one on video call because that could
have been a painful end to my life uh
but equally this fight is not a
competitive fight and I'm open to be
proven wrong it's my opinion but I think
a lot of people out there feel the same
way and from now on I I can't possibly
be giving my fight opinions on videos
and then interview someone and not say
what I really think and I did try and be
as respectful as I could you know and he
was like oh you're doing chisora down
yada yada and it's like I'm not I'm just
saying he shouldn't be in there with you
I don't think he's on your level we've
seen that twice you know why was there a
Trilogy for Deontay Wilder because there
was a level of Jeopardy there there's no
[__] Jeopardy here yeah I I get for
Fury he's in a difficult situation he's
picked the fight he wants the fight to
go ahead and he's got to sell that fight
and I'm kind of poking holes in this and
you know it's probably annoying fair
play you know you can say what you likes
I don't take myself seriously really
don't give a [__] because I think a lot
of people out there will want to hear
him respond to that and that's my
[__] job at the end of the day is to
say those things so that you lot hear
what you want to hear so let's hope
everyone
say Tyson anytime soon because yeah just
this chin it's it's not as you said you
know I'm a pretty boy okay thanks for
everyone who watched this video
appreciate you all don't forget to
subscribe and I'll see us on the next
one cheers